when we get a chance to go out there
we're evaluating those quarterbacks with
every single play not just throw but
every single check that they make at the
line of scrimmage every every bit of
leadership that they show in and out of
the huddle um we're there watching the
how they react to a specific play in
practice and so that got squeezed down a
little bit but with that said our
coordinators are doing a heck of a job
right now
as we as we sit here of
figuring out ways
to maximize those competitive
plays and periods and we feel confident
that we believe it'll all play itself
out um it's going to be completely open
and we're just going to take it day by
day
[Music]
matt nagy bears head coach on the
quarterback competition between the
incumbent mitch trubisky and the
newcomer nick foles super bowl mvp who
knows the offense better than trubisky
been with nagi two other times in kansas
city and before that in philadelphia
back when nagi was just first getting
started as an assistant coach under andy
reid
chris look it's a different kind of a
year we know that training camp no pads
until the middle of august no preseason
games none of the usual opportunities
for allowing a quarterback battle to
unfold in camp and one thing that nagi
said about folz yesterday he's at a
disadvantage not because he doesn't know
the offense but because he doesn't know
the receivers yeah that's a good time to
work with the receivers on the timing
the chemistry those things that
of all the stuff we can say trubisky
doesn't have one thing he does have is
the relationship with the receivers no
no doubt it's a real thing you know now
do i think that nick foles can make up
ground here even in this weird covet 19
training camp yes he can he's a pro he
understands this offense he's been
involved in it before so he'll
understand some of the nuances in the
route running everything about that but
yeah this throws another curveball or a
wrench or whatever you want to say into
the you know the offense of the chicago
bears because let's just be serious
that's where it all starts offense
that's what we got to talk about the
defense is fine the defense is a super
bowl caliber defense they could they
could shut down some of the best
offenses in football i mean eddie
goldman they lose him to coven 19. that
stinks because he's a beast but the
defense is going to keep them in a lot
of games can their offense just do
something to win some of those games the
defense did it for them last year that's
why they were eight and eight but can't
run the ball o-line not very good you
know you know past game schemes that i
think were very predictable now is
trubisky a part of that reason you know
it could can he not handle a lot of
stuff on his plate as far as the offense
is concerned and all that i don't know
those are things i hear sometimes in
chicago so it's all about figuring out
that quarterback situation and then it's
gonna be okay offense we can't be the
stew of crap that we were last year
especially with some of the players and
talent they have on that roster they
should just be better than that
and
you know we need to focus on the bears
but i'm curious about your own
experiences when it comes to that
important
topic of getting the right comfort level
with the receiver just give us a glimpse
give us an idea of of the challenge you
walk in as the new guy and you've got
the receivers there what what how does
that happen how do you get to a point
where you do have that comfort level
with your receiver yeah i think the big
thing is you know of course practice but
it's really going to be about after
practice where you'll get a better feel
for individual guys you know especially
you know you you get as a quarterback
you know during practice everybody runs
let's just say a curl route right you
know the guy runs 12 yards he curls back
and he comes back to 10. not everybody
runs that route the same way some guys
can get to that 12-yard point and put
their foot in the ground and make like a
a sharp angle and come right back next
guy's got to take a few extra steps and
rounds it out some guys just explode off
the line of scrimmage other guys are
patient guys who kind of use some build
up speed so those are the little things
you know and then you start to read body
language you start to get a feel for
body language like when i was in my
prime with joey galloway i didn't even
know need to know how many yards he was
running before he was going to make his
break i could see it with his little
headline and some of the nuances he did
that only i knew because i worked with
him every day to go oh joey's about to
break down and come out of this break
and i could throw the ball maybe before
i wanted to if the pressure was on me
because i'd go oh i've seen that body
language before i know he's going to do
it so that's where you want to get to
that's brady and edelman brady and grunk
that kind of guy devonte adams and
rogers and that's what you got to work
to get to uh through training camp
one of the realities of this
strange upside down season with no
preseason games
could we see especially in chicago
both quarterbacks being used in
september
while matt nagy makes a decision that
would be implemented the first week in
october as to who the starter is going
to be
uh you know you don't want to have
too much of a sense of interchangeable
parts at quarterback you need somebody
to be the team leader but if you're not
going to have a preseason to settle the
competition chris
maybe you use the early games the
regular season they open at detroit they
host the giants you know even those
first two games you don't want to lose
two out of the gates no but if you're if
you're not sure who the best guy is for
a stretch run that has seven playoff
spots available in the conference
maybe there is some wisdom in finding
ways to use both guys early on so you
can better evaluate how they do in a
game situation yeah i mean
i wouldn't suggest that
i i think that will cause issues now you
know maybe that's where they'll have to
be where they feel like it's so even but
i just would think what issues what
issues will it cost well you know i
one guy likes a certain certain style of
offense and these group of plays and
then here's another guy that doesn't
like those plays and wants a totally
different group a set of plays and
everything like that it's hard to tie an
offensive game plan together when it's
you know that way right that's where to
be my issue you know oh okay wait now i
gotta go to the trubisky package of
plays he doesn't like play action and
you know this run and blah blah blah
wait nick foles does like that and all
of a sudden you know you you it hurts
your ability for trickeration on the
defense is what i'm saying you know
they're they're going away this is all
over the place nothing's tying together
great offenses tie things together like
we talk about all the time make things
that are different look the same and all
that that's what i would worry about
more than not so you know going into
this mike i think you were with me right
i just felt like go with nick foles if
it's even close you go with nick foles
and then you can bring trubisky off the
bench and let him be superman but to me
if you start trubisky
it's just if it falters at all i just
think the world's gonna just you know
cry get him out of here get the hell out
of here we had enough for you and
there's no returning from that to a
degree so i i i don't know that that's
just my thought on the subject
i like the idea of true biscuit in a
taste some hill type of a package where
it's a strategic use of his skills okay
to get him on the field and maybe see
what he can do and then if he does well
in his limited
opportunities maybe you start to get the
fans rallying around him although they
were ready to bail on the guy before
last season's right even after a playoff
appearance we were they're not going to
be embracing yeah it was crazy right
they sensed it they knew what was coming
and uh so far they were right ryan pace
gm of the team said uh yesterday i feel
the full support from bear's ownership
he's got a 34-46 record after five
seasons one playoff appearance i mean
look
we know how this goes
you either perform or you don't and if
you don't you don't have a job and even
if he feels the full support now plenty
of guys have felt the full support until
they didn't and when the support goes it
goes quickly and if the bears uh go 4
and 12 5 and 11 this year i i don't
think anybody's going to be surprised to
see some major changes at the top chris
no and i i wouldn't be shocked either
you know ryan pace he's done a lot of
great things for that team there's no
doubt about that i mean you look at the
roster you know other than offensive
line
i come away pretty impressed at every
position i really do i mean you know
line we talked about the defense the
defense you just go through it it's it's
top notch at all three levels you know
offensively hey receivers tight end
drafted cole comet everything okay i'm
cool there running back pretty damn good
you know we got to figure out the
quarterback the offensive line that's
going to be the big thing here you know
for the chicago bears but you know
they're they're a team where
whoo you know we do worst-case best case
you know all that like their best case
they have a big gap to me like worst
case could be four and twelve and just
the offense falls apart and trubisky
craps down his leg and who knows what
else
but i don't know best case i wouldn't be
sure i wouldn't be shocked if they were
sitting here 11-5 and won a bunch of
games 20 to 14 and played through their
defense and and they won them games to
where all of a sudden they're you know a
wild card team or maybe one in the nfc
north i i'm i could see it going both
ways for the bears this year
we didn't expect them to win the
division the year that they did and with
the vikings in a strange kind of state
of transition the packers with the
awkwardness of jordan love being the
first round draft pick and no receivers
to replenish and devin functions who was
signed in free agency opting out for the
year and the lions being the lions who
they make you think that things are
changing and then it's time to play the
games and they don't the opening is
there for the bears to win the division
i agree with you and the opening is
there for the bears to have it all fall
apart again and i think nick foles is
going to be the key to whether or not it
goes in
one direction or the other if he can
stay healthy and play fairly well that
defense like you said is good enough to
help the bears have a great season all
right let's take a break after kyle
shanahan got his contract extension with
the 49ers the team locked up another
piece that has helped build the
foundation for one of the best teams in
the nfl we'll talk about the john lynch
extension when pft live continues right
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports